police are investigating a bomb threat
in a nationalist neighborhood homes are
evacuated roads blocked northern islands
enjoyed 20 years of reconciliation
between nationalists who identify as
mainly Catholic Irish and unionists who
define themselves as mainly Protestant
British but brexit has put pressure on
keeping the peace researchers have found
that brexit uncertainty is affecting
people's lives when asking about the
prospect of a hard border has revealed
that people are increasingly anxious in
these terms so they use the language
such as heartbreaking appalling
devastating disastrous not just because
of their the direct impact on their
personal daily experience but also
because they think it's going to be
enormous ly consequential for the
stability of the peace process here the
Irish border remains the central
sticking point of brexit it separates
Northern Ireland a part of the UK with
the Republic of Ireland and EU member
it's been open and without checkpoints
for 20 years both sides have benefited
politically and economically but if
brexit means a return to the so called
hard border of the past with security
barriers and watchtowers the armed
Republican group the new IRA says it
will attack the Prime Minister Prime
Minister Boyce Johnson says he's removed
the need for a hard border by keeping
Northern Ireland economically aligned
with the EU and also the rest of the UK
some customs checks however will now be
needed between mainland Britain and
Northern Ireland that details enrage
unionists any difference to the rest of
the UK is seen as a threat to their
British identity the Democratic Unionist
Party intend to vote against the deal in
Parliament while water described as
hardline unionists known as loyalists
are threatening civil disobedience on a
large scale if the deal goes through all
she interview Nyan ISM are opposed to
this even though those it would be
described as more moderate chance of
unionism are opposed to us so I don't
think any unionist could have
and what it means is it means in
economic united ireland that means we
are paved off from the rest of the
united kingdom not only his brexit put
pressure on piece is put pressure on
politics Northern Ireland's
power-sharing government at Stormont
collapsed two and a half years ago over
an alleged corruption scandal but
uncertainty over brexit has kept its
politicians away despite its flaws the
power-sharing government remains hugely
symbolic it was meant to be a chance for
people from different walks of life from
different political affiliations to work
together to shape their futures together
but it isn't working as it should be
a reminder of how fragile peace can be
neve barker al jazeera Belfast